everyone's do you want rope with
Collider and I'm here with Drew Pearce
hello how are you doing today sir very
good actually yeah it's been I think the
last time I saw you was well you claimed
to have seen me recently but I want to
say Hotel Artemus that was it Arclight
yes yes it was it was the ArcLight
yeah yeah so it's been a little bit it's
been in here has it really yeah that's a
yeah the F out of here yeah that's right
I am on Emilia exactly I'm stunned
because if you'd asked me where that
when that movie came out I would been
like six months no that was it was June
last year we're gonna go crazy yeah it's
crazy
um so has the last year been going let's
catch up right um it's been kind of good
it's insanely hectic there's lots going
on and it started obviously with Hobson
Shore which I actually got the phone
call about the day hotel optimist was
released in America actually um but and
then yeah and then I'm you know my next
stuff to direct is lining up and and I'm
working on a couple of big secret
franchise things that obviously I can't
talk about but yeah it's hectic it's
like being on thing on thing at the
moment but that's good right
so um Before we jump into these we're
I'm gonna dig in on your other stuff I
definitely want to know what I'm having
I'm asking this of a lot of people for
you what TV show would you love to guest
write and direct oh that is a genuinely
great question um I think maybe I think
that they're probably weirdly two
different answers I think if there was
ever a world where I could direct an
episode of flea back which will never
happen because a it has its own director
and be there's never going to be another
season but it is so glorious a TV show
and Phoebe so good that that just like
doing 25 minutes of that would be would
just be a dream so I think that's why I
would do as a director and then as a
writer all that it's it's it's a tricky
one I think it would probably be I'm
gonna use one from my childhood rather
than now I would love to have done an
episode of Buck Rogers in the 20th 21st
century oh I had a big thing I was a big
fan of book yeah and
and I rewatched a little of it recently
and it is of course batshit crazy but
it's also it's also really compelling
its bizarrely committed to get its a
very good like hang show because nothing
really happens cuz I guess they didn't
have any budget so there's like one
flight fight you know during each
episode but um but yeah so that that
made me I think it's also like it's
because I you know watched once upon
time in Hollywood recently and there's a
weirdly like like Buck Rogers
feels like if once upon time been set
ten years later that's 100% the show
that Rick Dalton would have been on you
know I also wonder I don't know if it's
the same with you but I I think Buck
Rogers was one of the first times I
realized I like women well you know it's
the first time that I realized I liked
half man half bird but but no I mean
like that's the weird thing like I
haven't even done the research I don't
know where but Rodgers comes in the time
line of Star Wars flirtation it's after
starting do one say Buck Rogers and I
could be wrong in 79 if I mean that's
what it looks and feels like so if and
it definitely feels like post Star Wars
but it's also in late the original
Battlestar Galactica it's it's that
really it's it's a very strange post
Star Trek kind of show as well it's a
it's a hang show and it's got some swing
to it that's what's kind of interest Oh
hundred percent for will is will know
Elmo yeah absolutely it's a whole thing
anyway I could see that right what movie
have you seen the most ever yeah Wow
I mean the trouble is it's probably
something from like real early teen hood
because you know was when you only had
your 20 VHS is that you taped things off
of the TV so I mean there's a world
where is actually The Breakfast Club but
I think probably as probably overall
it's die hard I would say it's weirdly
there's a chance it's repo man and
there's also a chance it's ladies and
gentlemen the fabulous stains but is
bids probably die hard got it um what
was the last thing you were really
obsessed with movie wise could be
anything anything
oh I'm currently in the throes of a
gigantic obsession with brutalist
architecture from one of my projects and
I just keep buying more and more and
more and more books on brutalist
architecture for example did you know
that Boston is one of the world centers
of concrete brutalist modeling modernism
from the 60s and 70s I can actually tell
you that Boston has an unhealthy amount
of concrete because I recently did a set
visit and I'm from the New England area
and it's like their Police Headquarters
it's just a concrete slab yeah
concrete's like that's that's Brutalism
and I said Brutalism and also hand in
hand with there's a like a font designer
a logo designer called Lance Wyman
who-who did like who did Massachusetts
Zoo I believe in the 60s and 70s and
I've gone down the deepest deep dive
rabbit hole on Lance Wyman over the last
two weeks that there's a possibility
that nobody has dived to eat deeper in
history into his life so those are those
are those are the two can you say what
project this is for or now yeah this is
for this is for this this big movie I'm
doing for Netflix called quartermaster
which you know it has a huge amount
about but it's a big techno thriller
with a contemporary female lead at its
heart and it's kind of a national movie
it's kind of a movie about our
relationship with technology but not
about AI so yeah and and and it's super
exciting and so I'm it's coming together
at the moment and we're hoping to shoot
it next summer and so I'm doing a hell
of a lot of research into what its gonna
look like is it do you think that's the
next thing you're directing it'll either
be that and hopefully is there's all
sort of thing I'm doing with our errands
do on who wrote Mandy he and I are
co-writing a horror movie that is coming
together really fast and is really
exciting so I don't know it's probably
one of those
but we'll end up being the next thing
but I've also discovered that I have
quite literally zero control over my
destiny when it comes to you know the
the plotting of let's use inverted
commas for the word career and so so who
knows but those are the two those are
the two that are vying for it at the
moment well the interesting Mandy was so
well received amazing yeah and it's so
well worth it was my favorite livery of
last year so is there any pressure to
try to you know because Mandy you know
the reviews raved I think I think it was
it's so specific and the thing I'm doing
with Chu is very different so so I don't
feel any real pressure in that I think
if I was going up against Mandy and
there was a death metal elements to the
project that I was doing with Stuart but
mine's not quite as gonzo perhaps um are
you guys writing with an actor in mind
or is it - it's kind of an ensemble
piece and you know I one meets actors
the whole time particularly when people
get a sniff of the projects being around
so I'm talking to a bunch of people but
there's no one specific
I think weirdly that the wrote the
writing I've done this year has
sometimes you are writing with an actor
in mind sometimes you are literally
writing with you know the actors in mind
but the ones this year have actually
come from the character first which
isn't always the way you know sometimes
I have a focal point what I do like to
make sure when I'm kind of coming into a
project is that there is a list of
actors that could be that character if
you know what I mean sure because
there's definitely also been times in
you know the last 10 years when I've
written a spec for example and then I
come to the end of it I'm like I love
that character there is literally no one
who can play it and I that seems like an
impractical way of spending my time yes
yeah although it could be that it's just
a good script for a calling card
yes and hopefully hopefully my the
scripts that I'm spending my own
horrible midnight hours writing at the
moment hopefully they are to get made I
see yeah I definitely before I forget I
want to ask you you were obviously
heavily involved in Iron Man 3
absolutely yeah right so I'm very
curious what are your thoughts on
Mandarin being part of shang-chi and you
know because the character is basically
absolutely you know um I mean I'll be
honest I'm just totally jazzed first of
all it's the most exciting piece of
casting in the Marvel Universe at the
moment as far as I'm concerned so so
that's a great start but look the way
the Mandarin always worked and we were
clear about it in Iron Man 3 and I was
doubled down clear about it in all hail
the king is it was an ancient mantle it
got co-opted and so a version of the
Mandarin being real and being out there
I am so happy and excited about that and
you know there's a reason we didn't do
any of the comic book versions of the
Mandarin in the context of our movie the
original stereotyped Mandarin from the
60s was a kind of symbol of of other
nests you know created as propaganda
technically and so we took that and turn
it on its head we we were like what are
the symbols of propaganda in the current
world and that dovetailed really nicely
with the idea of a Mandarin ie a false
other that can be used to blame domestic
things on now that I mean there are
versions in the comic books that are
totally doable like there's a fantastic
Matt Fraction version there is you know
the kind of techno crap Mandarin is a
really good idea so I don't know which
direction they're gonna go with it but
particularly in the context of a movie
where you know you have a genuinely
exciting Asian team making it and
another Asian lead I
it's I think it's brilliant bring it on
I am I'm constantly amazed you know how
hard it is to make a movie sure what
Marvel has done under Feige it doesn't
make sense no it's some it will never be
repeated already as a run and and who
knows how long this run goes and
hopefully it's another 10 years but in
cinematic history you won't get as dense
a universe and probably I would say as
you know even Lord of the Rings like as
as culturally significant an epoch of
filmmaking as what Kevin's done he's but
he's really good and you know I I kind
of owe a lot of my career to Kevin you
know he he plucked me in some ways from
from the UK and he's one of the best
people I've ever worked with so it it
doesn't surprise me what I think is so
enjoyable about it is I think somewhere
through the process and I think I know
what movie it was but I'm not gonna say
I think at a certain point Kevin
realized the thing that the whole rest
of summer movie makers are catching up
to which is delivering that you know the
old sequel mindset was given the same
again but more and I think Kevin
realized at a certain point that giving
the audience the same thing was a
diminishing return both creatively and
on a business level and that's when he
started to go what if we did the same
character but we put it in a different
genre you know and of course your
mileage may vary on how different the
movies are from each other but I love
the fact that I know they approach each
movie as if it's a movie from a
different genre and I think that's
absolutely nice
yeah well the thing that I find
fascinating is that each of these movies
basically what you're saying the Marvel
movies push each film pushes the comic
book genre comic book movie genre in a
new direction yeah and they're not
repeating anything no and that's the
reason why the genre is not slowing down
well and the
genre and also Marvel itself you know
because usually by this point in a epoch
or a trend someone else has picked up
the ball and run with it right
Marvel is still the one with the ball
still the one running you know and and I
think I do think it's because of the way
they the the way he keeps freshening it
up you know and the the next phase looks
to take that to quite an extreme yeah I
mean that was a mic drop at Comic Con
when he just said I'm just you know this
it's it's crazy yeah it's amazing yeah
also anyone who's not planning on
getting Disney Plus they're getting
Disney plus it's yeah I mean like it's
gone from being like oh well if you've
got kids Disney Plus is probably a good
thing too oh okay the content that we'll
be getting over the course of that you
you simply have to so yeah I it's if
they're gonna be the end I didn't mean
to dive into this model no it's fine
they're gonna be the first ones everyone
for the last number of years has talked
about movies and TV being interconnected
storylines stuff like that and no one
has made at work
no no one it has been the biggest bomb
in Hollywood no one can make it work and
I looked at Marvel's release calendar
and I'm like oh they're gonna be the
ones that actually make it work you know
yeah I would definitely not be surprised
if one division is the way they start to
bring in for example mutants exactly
moving on to back in John how how did
you get involved in this thing really
organically frankly I got a phone call
from Dave Leitch and leach and I know
each other quite well and Chris Morgan
who you've obviously spoken to who is
the architect of the the franchise he's
also the producer of Hobson sure and you
know there were a few months out and the
script still needed a bunch of stuff and
Chris is there trying to kind of keep
the juggernaut moving so I came on and
and gave some help and sometimes in my
secret job of helping out on movies that
will just be for a week or two weeks
this one just became a bit longer
to the degree that in the kind of in the
fast and furious pickup team style I
joined the team for a good chunk of it
so yeah I what would what was it like
working on him because this was one of
these things where David told me that it
was 13 months beginning to end for him
sure making this movie which is insane
for a film on this size and scope it's
absolutely insane and that's and I think
that's partly why I was there as well is
Dave and I already had a really good
shorthand there was no time less let's
get this on its feet and let's get it to
be not just like this that there's a
strange thing with like summer tentpole
filmmaking where from the outside I'm
sure when you know a day gets released
and people know that it's coming like
there was no sense that's one of the
reasons I love Dave there was never a
moment on this movie where there was a
cynicism to it it was all about we love
these characters I love the franchise so
I was like yeah brilliant let's make
let's absolutely make the best Hobbes
and sure move you know what I want to
see the best Hobson Shore movie so let's
go make it listen I love the action but
my favorite [ __ ] in the movie is sorry
for the language is already swore I
already already all the banter between
those guys you're like insulting each
other yeah that's my favorite part of
the movie absolutely because the the way
they insult each other is legitimately
funny yep and they do it with that
straight face and it's like good acting
while delivering this I I agree you know
um and you know I think what's what's
interesting about the banter is choosing
when to use it and when not to and on
some levels that's actually an editorial
decision as well for example the car
chase that I think everyone seen pretty
much all of in the trailers anyway that
that ends with the the scared and the
bus there was a ton of bantering in the
car and actually there's pretty much
none now and that was because if they're
just constantly bickering you can get
too much of a good thing and there are
some moments where they're bickering
actually feels like it's it's a
heightened reality but it's breaking the
heightened reality as well there are
moments when the Jeopardy of the
situation shouldn't
lead them to have a full-blown you know
three-minute snark fight well yeah but
then it takes away from the pressure of
the situation that's absolutely right
and that's one of the reasons that you
know I'm really proud of Hattie
Vanessa cooks character because I think
she is a really integral character I
think she has her own agency but in the
context of Hobson sure why she's great
is she gives them another thing to have
tension about constantly and in the room
because again a certain point T people
simply telling each other they don't
like each other whilst they're actually
trying to save the world it just starts
to ring a little hollow and so having a
clear and present a new point of
contention kind of allows you to keep
that banter alive David told me that he
his first cut was like 2:45 mm-hmm he's
not gonna do an extended cut on the
blu-ray it's gonna be just deleted
scenes yep
do you remember filming anything any
deleted scenes that you're sad that
didn't make it I died actually I loved
the car banter but it absolutely doesn't
need to be in the movie the the racecar
banter I just like I mean I
it'll be interesting to see if they're
you know fully new scenes or their
extended ones because the torture scene
for example there's a version of that
that is three times as long and was
incredibly funny the whole way same also
with one of the things that came up with
that I loved the most is the two
corridor fight when they're both in
separate corridors but there's
transparency there is a version of that
that is so much longer than the one
that's in the movie so I think David
also said there was like a six minute
more stuff and in the Samoa leading
those there was he shot so much stuff in
Samoa and again but you know during the
third act of the movie Samoa almost
feels like its own movie as well so I
think yeah there's a ton more there's a
mall that I was I saw the movie and I
leaned over I saw it with koi from
Collider and we were watching it and I
basically leaned over at some point and
I said they haven't even gone to Hawaii
my god so true there's a lot of movie
lay there is a lot of movies like I was
in bad boys 2 a little bit where it's
like there is nothing wrong with that
listen I love bad boys too but what I'm
saying is like there's a whole third act
of bad boys - you don't see coming
Oh totally it's like when they go to
invade the island absolutely the Hawaii
thing for me is like oh my god they
haven't even gone yeah no it's totally
true it's absolutely the case yeah
there's no way - listen if you go to see
Hobbs in sure there's no way you don't
get your money's worth
there we go no way I was actually trying
not to say that because it made me sound
like I was shilling soaps so hard then
didn't say but thank you for saying I
mean listen it's it's it's loaded yeah
100% really is okay so you wrap on
Hobson siya yeah then what starts
happening well so I'm doing Hobson Shore
backwards and forwards while I'm doing
all my other projects so I'm flying to
and from England a bunch to kind of help
out when needed and you know when Chris
has more time then he takes over the
script again so that was that was
honestly very organic and then while
that's going on I am I'm writing one
secret blockbuster there's a franchise
one which is so boring say I hate it
when people say but I literally can't
talk about it because it's a
pre-existing franchise in its massive
and I will be absolutely murdered I love
that you're doing like I can see you
doing like the franchise worst part is I
know what it is and I'm not gonna get
you in trouble on camera but I but I do
know what it is that's interesting
that's good to know and I'll throw it
out there because it's that Universal Oh
cheeky well that's one that I yeah that
I was working on there's actually
another one as well which is one they
took up a lot of the time this last year
but but you did I literally did just
start to sweat there in a kind of like
don't blame me they'll blame me right
know what's funny is I've hit up a few
people during interviews and I'm like so
let's talk about this and you can see
the look on their face like how the f
does he know I'm not even gonna ask I
don't even want to ask right and so so
there was there's that stuff and then
you know there's my my my ultimate
reality which is also being a director
and so I've been a you know post Artemus
I'm like reading other people's scripts
and
developing my own so quartermaster which
is at Netflix which is this huge thing
that would hopefully shoot next summer
and you know the movie with Aaron's dual
arm from from Mandy and plus a plus
another couple of things one thing
actually I've not mentioned anywhere
which is really exciting which has
happened very quickly in the last few
weeks is sterling K Brown who was
obviously one of the leads in Hotel
Artemis and is brilliant
he and I have developed a TV show for
him to be the lead of and I think we're
gonna be I mean who knows people might
it might not get it might not get bought
it might not happen but like that's
that's also something that's really
excited I've not found a TV idea that I
that I spark to for years and years and
I kind of started in TV I literally left
TV the week it became the golden era of
television and started working in
massive films so I moved to Los Angeles
and now all the films are shot where I
come from in Britain but so I'm like I
wouldn't say I'm the master of timing
but but yeah this this new project was
sterling it I think it's gonna be it's
it's like a project that's gonna allow
him to show the kind of swagger side of
what he does which we kind of got a
brief glimpse of in black panther and so
it kind of doubles down on that side of
what sterling can do so it's really how
does that work with him and his this is
our schedule we we will we will see I
mean he has the great thing about
network TVs there's a gigantic hiatus
completely I'm assuming that this thing
would be more like eight episodes or ten
episodes rather than it's definitely a
cable proposition I'll give you that
yeah exactly yeah so um you know and
that's the interesting thing about when
you've got an actor that's working on a
giant TV show like that it's you know
you've got this chunk of time that's
coming up every year you try and stack
it with as much good stuff as you can
and that trouble with doing that with
movies is as you know and I'm sure
everyone does movies fall apart the
entire time and so you know that's one
of the things we've been developing
movie ideas and this idea came along for
us both and we just thought oh I think
we can do this well then like I say it
all the time but that's the reason my
huge filmmakers are developing three
different things hopefully because you
don't know what's gonna get the money
100% yeah and the bigger thing that no
one seems to understand is scheduling
absolutely that's like the number one
thing there's only so many stars your
schedules are full and then you know
like if you you know I've heard people
losing someone because of one week Oh
dad you can lose someone because of two
days and yeah I think the other thing
that's happened in the last few years
that people maybe don't know is the
problem with booking someone who is for
example in a long-long going franchise
is not just the work they'll do once
every two years that's you know a 90 day
shoot on that movie it's the gigantic
slices of time that they have to promo
the movie and they often you know drop
down in chunks during the time when you
might be hoping to make a film with them
and that's you know that's happened to
me and it's happened to most of the
filmmakers but I know know especially
like if you're in a movie like Avengers
endgame right you're promoting for a
month yeah and you know the additional
photography of that movie those movies
is as long as most other films anyway
because there's a certain iterative
nurse - you know how the Russos and how
Kevin work oh completely and but they
talked about it freely
oh no I know and that's why I very clear
not schooled them reshoots I think with
a plus them yeah I mean that's the
Marvel phrase ROM but but and sometimes
you're they're restructuring them I mean
like sometimes you're it's not even
about being ill-prepared sometimes you
get to the edit and you know you have a
Thor the dark world situation you can
rewrite the movie or the dark world
situaion that but and so and when that
and when that occurs usually as a
filmmaker you don't have the resources
to go oh [ __ ] only I'd thought of this
thing if only I'd seen that coming if
you're Marvel then it's like great let's
try that with so it's actually I think
people often
there's an old way of thinking about
additional photography that it's fixing
things or that it is in some way because
the the movie is broken
it is often because it's the evolution
of the story and the chance to actually
shoot more those in my own feeling and
I've said it again and again when people
talk about reshoots and additional
photography sometimes people look at it
as a you know they're like the sky is
falling until you see the movie on
opening day the movie is not the movie
100 said when you see it opening day
that is the movie you're judging not
anything that's happened before and if
the movie works you know like for
example I believe rogue one went through
a decent amount of reishi absolutely you
know I had to yeah and so you know that
movie has I like rogue one a lot and
that stuff with Vader at the end is all
from the additional photography so and
that's and that's I think that's the
thing about there is you know a hoary
old cliche which is you know a film gets
written three times you know one once on
the page once on the shoot and once in
the Edit and the interesting thing about
an edit now if you have the resources is
you can do all three of those things
right you know again you can get another
cycle out of it like it so it's it's a
it can be a tiring way to work because
you it does give you that sense of the
the finite nature of a movie is
sometimes how you get yourself over the
end line and if it keeps unfolding then
then just it's exhausting but it's also
a really brilliant resource yellows in
whatever makes the movie the best class
right yeah and if you have the advantage
I mean look listen with Marvel they have
the IP they make so much money on
merchandise theme parks you know if it
cost them another 50 million or 100
million in the scheme of things it
doesn't matter also and I you know this
I this may even sound naive but it's
absolutely true and it's from experience
Kevin won't let something out the door
until he thinks it's as good as it can
be to the degree that like on Iron Man 3
I think we were in the edit
two weeks passed when the DCP you know
the king the black box that has the one
version of the the movie on it two weeks
past when it was even supposed to be
technically possible to then distribute
the movie it literally the DCP got taken
on a plane to the Russian premier which
was the first one of the the kind of
tour so you know that's and that's
basically because Kevin locked the door
and he was like no one's coming to get
me we're gonna make this as good as it
can be I love that yeah it works
yeah and he's also the best yeah but
that's right if you've got someone in
that position who isn't actually as good
as he is then that can be a horrific ly
destructive version of it but you know I
think there's an aspect where if we
don't trust Kevin Feige by now then I
don't know what he's supposed to do to
earn your trust I've said this again and
again that's why I know that Disney plus
and the movies will all work yeah
because it's being helmed by Kevin Feige
and you know having been inside that
family you know for a while you know
both with Runaways and then Iron Man and
with all hail the king that that drip
down applies to all of the very small
and close-knit group of people that work
you know with and under Kevin they you
know that's that's the ethos completely
I have to stop here and just say that I
look forward to talking to you about
these other things they are announced
but congrats on being part of Hobbs and
Shaw thank you so much it's such a blast
yeah and I it's playing an IMAX for I
think a week I recommend seeing it in
IMAX because IMAX is always the best
yeah for sure and but anyway thank you
so much for coming up salute pleasure